The answer is we will store a function object in that sagas array.
From the f to the end curly brace is the definition of a function object, and
that is the value that we're pushing into the sagas array.
A lexical scope is actually just characters of code that you defined in
a file somewhere.
And that's not actually a value that can be stored anywhere in a variable or
as an element of an array.
An execution context is one of these boxes that we
see pictured here wherein we find stored key value pairs.
And fundamentally this is not something you can even have a reference to.
And similarly it can't be stored in an array.
There is no anonymous function being called here.
The closest thing is this function object.
But since there are no parens appearing after it,
we will not be invoking an anonymous function.
And, therefore, we won't be getting the result of an anonymous function.